Good Night Moon.
By Margaret Wise Brown.
Pictures by Clement Hurd.
In the great green room, there was a telephone, and a red balloon,...
...and a picture of the cow jumping over the moon.
And there were three little bears sitting on chairs,...
...and two little kittens,...
...and a pair of mittens.
And a little toy house,...
...and a young mouse.
And a comb, and a brush, and a bowl full of mush.
And a quiet old lady who was whispering "hush".
Good night room.
Good night moon.
Good night cow jumping over the moon.
Good night light, and the red balloon.
Good night bears.
Good night chairs.
Good night kittens.
And good night mittens.
Good night clocks.
And good night socks.
Good night little house and good night mouse.
Good night comb and good night brush.
Good night nobody.
Good night mush.
And good night to the old lady whispering "hush".
Good night stars.
Good night air.
Good night noises, everywhere.